on est parti pour diane wood alors l'an
dernier toi par exemple tu l'avais qu'au
bien de ton bord combien de ta mok et
comment est ce que tu es prospecter
qu'est ce que tu attends de voir en
première année
je l'avais tiers 2 savait qu'à être tout
seul dans son tir 1 et 2 jours dans le
tir de van mobley
je l'avais assez haut j'étais assez au
chu souvent assez très positif sur les
joueurs qui pour moi ont des qualités
athlétiques plus plus plus et en fait
moi jen green s'est pas simplement ce
genre de deux gardes us qu'on voit
souvent non ses qualités athlétiques
elles sont pas elles sont vraiment
au-dessus de la moyenne elles sont
vraiment très très très très très bonne
en fait pour moi est ce que je mange du
défi c'est pour ça que j'étais très
chaud sur dja mort hante aussi je
pouvais pas trop décembre dernier de
voir des années d'après et je peux pas
trop défendre et de naïveté c'est que on
se demande souvent aux quais cahill
athlétique c'est n'importe quoi ça
apporte en réalité une facilité des
décisions parce que ils crient tellement
d'écart peuvent se créé tellement
d'espoir ce qu ensuite se bat pour faire
la bonne passe le bon choix c'est
souvent un peu plus simple là où pour
moi la métropole ou halliburton autres
on parlera après sont quasiment des
génies parce que
le tout et durant tout est dur ce qui se
crée pas tout la séparation mais arrive
quand même à faire les bouchons déjà une
green je pense je pense que je le pense
toujours à mon avis à faire changer
tellement qu'il aille à un pacte et
surtout scoring individuel dans début de
carrière faire des lights les bouées
dans le poulpe à trois points avec comme
de soucis principaux le dribble et le
manque de physique qualité ce qui lui
permet de parler au cercle un jour avec
cette exclusivité la de voiliers plus au
cirque
je pense je pensais que surtout que
parce qu'on allait vous ce qu'on a pu
voir fezensac la vigne par exemple
pourrait se passer à dire dans les
années 3 4 5 un développement de la
création pour pour les autres qui fait
que bah je l'avais au dessus d'un jeans
je l'avais reçu d'un scotty barnes au
dessus d'un d'essayer de ses droits
parce que je pensais que est-ce qu'on
est serai toujours là et qui pourrait se
développer dans autre chose et du côté
un peu négatif qu'est ce que tu lui
reprocher sketch show sur lesquels il a
positivement surpris vous maniez joey
gates a déçu sur des points faibles qui
sont vraiment trop faible ou des poids
moyens qui sont finalement des points
faibles pour toi je reconnais on est
d'accord sur une début début de carrière
sur des balbutiements
le l'aspect défensif c'est un peu
décevant on va pas se mentir il n'est
pas toujours le plus impliqué il est pas
tout le temps fait pas tout temps les
bonnes lectures l'appréhension est pas
exceptionnel j'étais aussi assez déçu de
son utilisation angela knight je trouve
que cette année c'est beaucoup mieux
ce qui fait par un jason hart est mieux
que ce que c'est brian shaw je trouve
pour je sors de trois quatre matches des
guides nightlife franchement c'était
mieux shooté n'était pas toujours mis en
avant et il avait besoin d'un bon meneur
à côté de lui mais on les mettait
jarrett jack ou d'autres qui étaient
vraiment là pour faire plein de plein de
tirer mais ça n'a pas vraiment de
développer dans certaines choses qui est
arrivé avec moins de moins de code
peut-être moins après mais ça que
l'appréhension collective et la
l'influencent défensive était pendant
les grosses questions elles sont un peu
décevant encore
ouais ouais je te rejoins là je te
rejoins là dessus
défensivement donc ça avec eux qui
n'avaient pas beaucoup d'applications
comme tu le disais j'ai l'impression que
c'est un point commun qu'ont la plupart
des jours d itt knight et on va le voir
cette année avec notre ami canadien qui
défend peanuts ou michael foster
et
après on avait effectivement aux
créations collectives est ce que le
joueur pouvait voir au delà que son
champ de vision il y avait des
situations drive in teak mais avait peu
de vraies situations piqué normalement
parce qu'ils ont généré peu comme tu
disais et il raté beaucoup de joueurs
ouverts sur les côtés moi et ça on va
tout ce que tu trouves qu'en nba où il
quand même beaucoup plus porteur de
balle cette année est ce que tu trouves
qu'il ya quand même des des signes
avant-coureurs de choses positives qui
se met en place alors on va le voir là
dans le clip parce que l'équipe que le
match que j'ai payé je voyais c'était un
match avant la la
joeystarr c'est un match à au pélican où
il fut pour moi un de ses meilleurs
matches la création collective tout il
ya vraiment une très bonne chose qui
sont faites
et en fait ça se voit que c'est plus le
même type jane green d'octobre novembre
c'est déjà mieux appréhender une sur
demi terrain c'est faire des murs genre
qui n'est pas toujours aidé par ses
coéquipiers qu'il soit refuse les prenez
trois points sur pick'n pop ou alors
rate des choses simples donc pas dans la
ligne de stats ou dans la croix sont
visuellement l'impression que c'est
qu'il fait pas toujours les bons choix
mais c'est pas que de sa faute mais en
réalité
je pense que au moins il a tout est là
et je suis il n'y a pas de sortir du
train ou être déçus car contexte
collectif qui fait qu'ils sonnent n'a
pas pour but de gagner des matches ils
ont pour but ils ont drafté quatre jours
au premier tour ils ont fait ils ont
fait le projet qui épie djè ils sont là
pour des matchs faire jouer les jeunes
au maximum se montre sauvegarde rumba et
n'a pas le droit de jouer on sait pas
pourquoi mes bras panon
et ça mais
je suis pas déçu tu me suis pas surpris
non plus tu vois je m'attendais à ça moi
personnellement je m'attendais à rentrer
je m'attendais pas peut-être parce que
les gens autant sur ses côtes on va dire
mais mais c'est vrai que je suis pas je
suis pas déçu je suis c'est positif en
fait je pense que c'est comme ça que ça
doit se passer pour lui donc pour moi il
aura trois quatre années où les verra
des galères sur le plan collectif des
galères cependant création mais qui sont
nécessaires dans son développement dans
le tchat
tout alors doit être cette idée à des
jets du stroma que je valais prendre
juste avant petite question genre est ce
qu'il ya des des personnes qui sont pas
du tout fan de tshela nouvelle équipe
peut-être justement lui tombe dessus
pour que la zone hyper intéresse t de
d'avoir des retours là dessus
pour faire une une transition pour toi à
terme est ce que ça peut être un porteur
de balle principal d'une équipe et
est-ce qu'il faut lui associer comme
joueurs autour de lui pour qui vraiment
il rayonne dans son développement
est ce que c est pas ça passe par un
meilleur intérieur est ce que ça parte
pas meilleur meneur de jeu comme a pu
avoir des vignes booker pour passer un
cap est-ce que ça passe par un meilleur
système collectif est ce que ça passe
par je met des sous il dit très
défensive comment on fait pour le cadre
de ciné c'est quoi le lac de
développement et après on prendra les
remarques du chat et les questions
je pense que c'est un peu tôt mais tu
vois je pense que tu es fan d'une équipe
où j'ai beaucoup de doutes en fondée sur
un peu comme avec la ville en fait on
lui a juste mais tu es bon joueur de
basket à côté et quand as tu es bon
joueur de basket à côté et pas que des
gens contrat rookie côtier par un coach
pas bon ça change la donne
parce que alors oui bien sûr un strike
pour l'aider à les ouvrir le cercle bien
sûr des dvd cindy capable de shooter
bien sûr un deuxième porteur de balle ce
que peut être deux retraités de roseanne
pour la ville ce qui a été prévu à
nouveau le pourvoi des bulls qualité
chris paul pour divine booker succèdent
parce que ça en fait ça ça permettra
green de faire ce mandat création
secondaire c'est à dire on va le mettre
en mouvement voit le sait pas lui qui va
initier il va surtout finir mais pau il
pourra aussi par van innis et mais
je pense que
leur contexte pour lui est d'abord de
[Musique]
c'est d'abord je pense travailler sur ce
dribble qui pour moi et on va le voir
limite encore son jeu et quand il aura
amélioré sont en deuil a tout changé
l'entraînement que les voilà d'avoir ce
travail individuel d'abord eden va
offrir beaucoup de choses ensemble
alors du coup on nous dira si vous
estiment souvent le contexte
environnement sportif fo stuff le
meilleur exemple c'est ramon penn the
white man at the right place alors ne
parle pas de cameron peine
serra des jours que j'ai le plus détesté
de toute ma vie de fan qu'il est il est
aussi passé chez moi après 4 un
transfert qui envoyez-nous légendes
telles conditions de ok si cameron peine
pour moi c'est un c'est un mystère de
ouf il ya des jours comme ça qui arrive
à rebondir est ce qu'il avait fait
plusieurs contextes et qu'à chaque fois
il était il était dans sa lecture du jeu
en six jours il était exécrable mais
effectivement arriver au bon endroit
qu'on est l'amour et qu'on ait une idée
avec toi en tant que joueur c'est
forcément mieux un bon il faut aussi car
pacs alors pour regarder la beauté des
tirs éclatent sur bois car pâques c'est
quand que tu as tu des spots
publicitaires dans la ville en écrans
géants qui te disent faille regard pas
conquis une raison
et je me disais aussi alors il
m'a donné ce avec les mii quel régal bah
merci à toi et où se dérouleront les
finales régionales avant le final four
j'ai la preuve je pense que tout se fait
du côté de portland sauf si je me trompe
non ça à 9h la new orleans hockey excuse
moi je crois vous l'avez dans le monde
en plus dans le aa dans le jour le site
tourne à man vous avez le final for new
orleans
louisiane heures voilà c'est écrit là et
après d'autres matches peu plus trop
vous dire et on a o'brian qui nous dit
au début de la saison il m'énervait mais
ces derniers matchs après le all star
break qui m'a prouvé le contraire est
faux toujours effectivement le laisser
du temps et que jeunesse se fasse c'est
ce que nous disait aussi jedi et padawan
et après joe qui nous dit par hayao
kessy qu'elle brel à cameron pnc
moi je vois là je pourrais je pense
jamais l'apprécié parce qu'il m'a
traumatisé la vie avec sa tête de fouine
ces célébrations et son comportement qui
m'a rendu ouf mais tant mieux pour lui
si s'il a pu rebondir on va pouvoir du
coup passée au film que tu nous a
préparés ou on a une playlist sur sept
alors j'en avais ras une autre de mes
petites il veut tout casser ce soir
c'est là c'est la soirée des charges qui
désole un peu là
pour la serait déchargée moi c'est une
maison de la maison de chat
qu'est ce que tu veux nous montrer sur
ce film qu'est ce qu'on doit être
vigilant et pourquoi tu ne parles de
problèmes au niveau du terrible sur quoi
tu es sur quoi tu tu veux accès est ce
que ces changements de direction est ce
que ces changements de vitesses est ce
que c'est créer un écart c'est ce que
c'est
quoi que tu crains car il sait le faire
je pense que jamais parce qu'on fait
enfin car il sait le faire c'est son
dribble est trop à droite ces genres
jours on peut penser qu'il revendrait
dont on le voit dribbler oui peut faire
plus mais n'arrivent pas à accéder au
cercle on dribble nous sommes
alignés verticalité avec son dribble
elle lui parle là dessus doit travailler
aussi je mange un petit peu désolé mais
est en fait ce que je voulais montrer
dans ce clip c'est et progrès la
création
des oublis défensifs ils sont notables
un niveau de choc mais king qui est
quand même intéressant dans un match
une équipe de des pélicans qui était pas
non plus super héros complète et venait
de faire le trait de céder ma colonne
qui ont fait houston n'est pas non plus
tu une incroyable équipe c'est ça que je
voulais montrer aussi parce que voilà
qui me disent ça n'est pas incroyable
des non plus donc c'est pas assez pas un
mismatch mismatch quoi
vous voulez dire
la qualité de l'opposition voilà ils
sont pas non plus c'est un golgoth tout
gêné le doigt trop en faire ou alors il
est totalement oui une défaite mais
devant 200 points mais seront à -33 et
donc
du coup nous permettre de remettre
depuis le début
donc là
on va mettre ça au ralenti alors pour
ceux qui est qui suivent pas 12 tonnes
quotidien peut pas leur en vouloir parce
que l'équipe est elle au fond du gouffre
l'ipcc le numéro zéro il à l'aps la
nasse et est là on commence du coup je
n'ai pas trop de décalage est avec moi
on commence avec un ris un 3-points
transition c'est quelque chose sur le
duc ou fluide toi au niveau du geste au
niveau de la mécanique et est ce que il
est latéralisé est ce que quand il
reçoit le ballon côté gauche il va
plutôt de tuer le mannois plutôt driver
ou pas encore pas du tout il est
toujours à celle et catherine chauvin
green toujours
quand on voyait en fiba il veut y avait
une personne dévouée au site je veux
c'est des fois ils étaient 1 a perdu
catch and shoot c'était la seule fois en
vrai cas d'école du tout parce qu'au
lycée du tout bien qu'ils aient tous les
ballons donc comme
je fais de quelque chose ou superflu de
compacts nature et on n'a pas vraiment
s'arrêter en transition offrant une
solution aux tirs extérieurs
enseignerait qualité faux
est ce que
le voir n'existe alors je reviens en
corner est ce que tu peux le voir
existait toujours des sorties de
dribbles est ce que tu trouves qu'il
serait axé bien où elle est plus elle
annonce une fin de chaîne
non je pense que c'est les deux
il ya un manque de puissance parfois sur
le coup d'oeil à son âge et c'est normal
avec sa musculature très longiligne il
est doté pour bien voir et j'aime
beaucoup c'est un goût d'un met là les
dossiers sur les deux îles est pas il
est pas
il a deux possibilités de poids pas
trois points qui prend pas quoi et
là dessus c'est mais c'est pas le truc
le plus optimal mais tout ça peut très
positif sur cinq ghosn oui mais tout
là-dessus il n'y a pas le même contexte
c'est une mais avec un vrai stress 5 il
n'a pas encore plus ouvrir des choses
dans son
besoin on a par exemple il ya un mois
ouais j'aimerais avoir le respect singh
ce qu'était ce qui est dans les dé
cristiano réalité mais christiane n'est
pas tout le temps des prêtres huit ans
les fils et les filles quoi voilà il n'y
a pas de chauves content d'être là donc
c'est compliqué mais ces avancées dans
ce machin je trouve que à la création
qui avait des vraies des vraies bonnes
choses de la part de schengen qui n'ont
pas toujours été ressentie dans les
stats et c'est pour ça que bah ouais moi
et d'autres petits voilà ici il faut
regarder les matchs en entier quoi quoi
quoi il ya un joueur à faire trois
passes décisives mais andy situation de
parce qu'ils sont bonnes sur match si je
remets celle là parce que sur celle là
ce que j'aime bien à l'or olympique n
pop on a du coup le rôle là stop je
frise tout le monde voit la base dans le
corner ici donc je sers active d'un
corner c'est ce que ces mortiers n'diaye
marcq n'diaye martin kelly et martin et
donc voilà pas dans le corner et lui il
a le le mot dire l'intuition de
ressortir pour un meilleur shooteur ici
et donc la ceca lipides j'ai
donc qui finalement fait un petit stade
s'était appuyé célébrer le terrain oui
il ya des il ya des bons flashs on le
voyait plus en galère alors encore une
fois ici un drive-in qui tout simple
vous voyez plus en galère sur la il est
vraiment poussins toi le dream déjà le
jeu qu'on fait là il peut pas aller
voter parce que le dribbler passer par
une phase de poule qui tourne mal et je
vous recruter dans le ballon derrière
moment il est obligé de faire cette
passe à la passe est bonne le tir est
bon mais là et puis au moment là lors
que le replay le repli défensif sur
hébert bionz est assez cataclysmique
comme toutes les transitions des rockets
de st c'est pas le seul mais là dessus
beaucoup de beaux loi qui donc vous dire
ça regarde beaucoup la balle ces regards
c'est un sonic pas trop exigeante et
voilà c'est pas c'est pas croyable
personnes communiquent pour arrêter le
ballon je crois des questions en même
temps tu me tues me coupa c'est des
clips eu un peu peu importants
[Musique]
guy qui nous demandent alors déjà un
green avec le public sur la zone et quoi
d'après vous bah pas évident à dire
parce que gregg popovich il a beaucoup
de jeunes talents ces dernières années
mais qui avaient tous la même limite
c'était le dribble justement est pour
l'instant finalement le lot celui qui
s'en sort le monsieur qui avait déjà le
meilleur dribbles de base donc
l'espérance pas forcément le meilleur
contexte du jeu développé par la défense
sont à la défense mans du ballon et
aller cataclysme mais du coup leur
maître jetons prix de l'essence et sur
des ventes et g l'accord de progression
des ventes et g et puis il le perd
complètement parce qu'il est un regard
que jonas valanciunas des regards à
droite à gauche à droite à gauche
regarde le ballon voilà c'est là une
bière c'est compliqué et là c'est normal
pour ces jeunes gens là c'est tout à
fait normal mais tout comme le confiait
jacques lavigne fait toujours ça ne
compte pas ouais ouais bah oui je sais
je vous dit et bien une question aussi
ce qu'est ce que c'est que vous ne peut
peut devenir ce serait de 5 j'espère
parce que c'est nous navre est touché
mais c'est mounir fussent plein de 3
points donc qui les prennent quoi faut
qu'ils les prennent mais oui c'est ça
c'est ce serait possible ça serait
possible serait même nécessaire
surtout qu'apparemment
je prends ta question qu'ils assurent
les cas soc de la draft on peut pas en
parler est ce que tu disais tu es un
super singh
j'aimerais bien regarder un peu ce qui
se passe du côté de memphis avec steve
adams et je trouve un que steven adams
qui est pas un oestreicher hype rend
vraiment de sharepoint bien meilleur
cette année parce qu'il ya une qualité
de pose d'écrans exceptionnelle pour de
bloquer toute la défense et les cédez
jamais navigué sur des petits périmètres
et le bonifier tout simplement
est-ce que tu trouve qu'au niveau de du
screenplay du côté de houston c'est
correct
non c'est pas mon traitement c'est pas
mon piano ne posent pas d'écran et après
les intérieurs c'est des russes et des
jeunes qui est jaime martinez leur merde
poseurs d'écran il est très intéressant
je trouve dans le dans le dans le
comment ça s'appelle la pose d'écrans et
le rôle pour exposer bien certes mais la
pose d'écrans comme chuté à l'adams adam
faisait face aux deux écrans de suite
well à chaque fois que vous êtes
sûrement parce que ces experts le gigot
perles et des screen assister tout ça
c'est ça les donc en fait il n yad suit
jérémy 10e minute un nouveau clip du
match pour des clippers aussi c'est vrai
j'en aurais je ne m'en souvenir mais
il ya au niveau date la pose d'écrans
n'est pas n'est pas incroyable parce que
halperin seung hoon
à ce ce corps pour pouvoir justement
retardé bien le joueur et les cette
compréhension du jeu moi je pense que ça
peut vraiment radio de pitié drôle
offensivement hyper intéressant quand
elle peut rendre compte entre notre
sécurité est venu pour totalement bloqué
le défenseur adverse là on voit je vois
l'équipe et je le remets il ya un pick
and pop mais internationaux ni fait
aucun décalage par son screen voilà il
ne touche pas un pouce de cap
action d'écran plus que faire l'écran et
pourtant c'est un problème plus
américain je pratique souvent les jeunes
américains pour ça ouais mais alors
il va falloir développer ça et quelque
chose peut-être que ousmane garuba qui
le protège journée 2-3 fait déjà mieux
par son expérience un ballon de rugby
c'était vrai c'est vraiment un très bon
poseurs de la salle était pourtant que
j'ai pas vu le match et qui peut
indiquer des roquettes mais ouais
c'était vraiment un bonbon vont poser un
écran voilà aurait mené ses obligés
passons donc pour jouer
quelqu'un qui nous dit alors
un des meilleurs d'écran de la ligue
donc steven van je pensais oui c'est
exceptionnel scott simmons adam se fait
en termes de qualité des grands
d'ailleurs j'ai mis un clip il n'ya pas
longtemps d'une action que pour du wafa
pick and roll entre john elle vit les
acquis dit c'est un copier coller dans
un james simmons adam savait que l'écran
et jour où l'eau certes mais je reste en
train de traîner pour bloquer le
défenseur il m'aimait fait ça pour
bloquer c'est vraiment une master class
et chez total danel tests qu'il le fait
est excellemment bien aussi le pin donc
oui
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose d'autre
que tu voudrais ajouter sur lequel on
est parvenu on a vu son action contre
les clippers où il ya ce décalage de
cristaux nicolas batum de l'exposition
traces en préparation va la création
séparation la géla l'explosivité du
drive sur une axonaise actionnaires une
très bonne saison défensive il
s'améliore vraiment mais on voit que le
premier pas il est bon il ya aussi une
action un peu plus tard oui c'est une
bonne lecture et reconnaît le mismatch
de sting ordinateur il fait une passe à
une main avec rebond
pour pour son intérieur pour que ce
match ait des super encourageant c'était
avant l'ostar break il va au tie break
bon il ya le concours de dunk voilà tout
ce qu'on veut et depuis les îles et sur
cette lancée et score et joue de plus en
plus houston gagne pertes raison c'est
pas le problème ils ont gagné quelques
matches mais voilà c'est une chance
c'était un bon résumé de ce que de ce
qu'on a avec green il ya des qualités
athlétiques il ya du catch and shoot qui
est un peu présents des prémices de
création et des soucis dribbles les
soucis un peu de côté ce collectif les
soucis de défense qui sont quand même à
noter là j'aime bien il s'arrête et
repart à l'hésitation et ils vont peut
être changer tristesse pas là changement
de vitesse balle en main c'est pas
compliqué mais c'est et ça a l'air
simple mais ça reste du très bon niveau
le toit le deuxième bien compris les
matières encore sur sur la mais il se
rattrape bien qu'une bonne passe pour le
chat quand on me dit qu'il ya un
pourtour de balle et lettonie et à mes
yeux il ya trois choses qu on note
souvent c'est être capable de dribbler
dès demain ça a l'air con mais ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui arrivent à une
bouée qui peuvent pas dribbler dès
demain être capable de changer de
direction c'est à dire de changer de
mains quand tu es en dribbles et de
changer de vitesse donc il ya des
joueurs qui vont très vite mais qui sont
sans qu'une seule vitesse et du quotiden
facile à défendre mais les joueurs qui
peuvent décéléré et très accélérée dans
leurs draps et c'est ce qui les rend les
plus les plus élite d'ailleurs c'est là
dessus que les james heard anelka jones
itx qui ne sont pas les athlètes est
plus explosif sont des tueurs ben alors
moi c'est qu'ils sont capables de
changer pour vitesse de très vite
réaccélérer et on va parler d'un mec
juste après tyrese halliburton qui est
pas du tout un athlète mais qui change
très bien de son propos reid et c'est ça
qui le rend très très dangereux ballaman
maintenant
ok on a
o'brian qui dit j'ai beaucoup aimé la
vie de dallas ont donc une gamme
d'utiliser nos le système des warriors
face à des écrans et des trois
helvétique tu t'es gentil petit vidéo
ouais ce matin je pense qu'on peut le
dire dans quand je pense moi je
reviendrai dans le dans le tweet quand
je serai j'aurai la chance d'être dont
on cause on fera du cumul avec + effet
j'ai clip et trois matchs de curling à
et j'avais un petit extrait où il fait
deux trois actions où il est utilisé
voilà en fait l'une des manières coup on
peut les voir arriver un peu le plus à
cacher ses soucis et avenant à utiliser
ses forces en est une c'est en posant
d'écran pour ensuite rouler fort vers le
cercle et ouais c'était ce que j'avais
mis de bâtons
vous regardez ça alors ça te gêne pas je
te laisse et j'avais le chat un peu plus
j'entre dans l'esprit d'un projet
d'envergure est en train de la défense
la défense en transition avec un smiley
oui mais c'était pas assez simple c'est
vrai c'était pas compliqué du tout qui
nous disent merci davance pour ma
question sur les cas sociaux entre
guillemets car dans two door kinect le
loup nba il y en a est ce qu'une
franchise avant drafté font des enquêtes
de personnalité bien entendu c'est la
base cela vaudra au c'est c'était
surtout que c'est un investissement
financier une sélection à la draf donc
c'est des millions de dollars qui sont
donnés des militants on peut pas prendre
de risque avec des genres instable les
joueurs du profil hors terrain et est
trop complexe des fois on le prend parce
que le talent est trop et trop fort mais
toutes les franchises lors des combats
et notamment lors des interviews
pré-draft tout france construit des
franchisés pour des work-outs mais ce
qu'elle veut c'est ce qu'a visitée
sentir le joueur lui parler on peut voir
un peu l'entourage donc assurer les
hauts cadres du personnel et c'est
extrêmement important ce qu'on appelle
les intel et des enquêtes sur les
entourages on les appelle des coachs de
risques ou des coachs ancien des coachs
qu'il a affrontés c'est une vrai travail
d'espions qui est fait par les scouts et
parallèlement des fonds pour lui il ya
un exemple l'entente de chant de la
porte parce que mon petit caisse les
murs ya un exemple qui s'ouvre donné
c'est alors c'est un peu cliché mais ma
famille qui pendant ces workshops tout
les joueurs au bout sur des exercices
ridicule juste pour voir comment ils
réagissent et donc comment il supporte
le
un effort un effort hyper intense
et et voilà et on nous c'est qu'on sait
que maintenant il ya eu beaucoup de
maires que les les années intel sont
vraiment majoritaire sur peut-être
parfois les résultats physique notamment
lors des trois dernières années avec le
contexte sanitaire où les équipes
pouvaient pas forcément voir les joueurs
en vrai et que les interviews
individuelles via zou
autres ont été goûtés complètement
décisif c'est ce que nous disaient qu'il
y ait healy il ya trois ans non
de gonzaga ou globalement les équipes
elles se elle se base est vraiment là
dessus
non
sinon pour les sk du jour du coup
pendant sept jours cette draft là où en
terme de mental est un peu inquiet ou en
terme de comportement n'est pas hyper
rassurer tout à l'heure quelques uns des
échanges a donné vie au niveau du
comportement il ya des choses qui le
haut niveau du body one 4g des choses
fils jack était un peu est-ce que tu
partes h ou est-ce que d'autres joueurs
qui te demander non
non sur fois plus sursis devant choisir
quelques-uns jeu sur pas de baldwin
alors il peut être excusable sur pas mal
de choses je l'exclus sur plein de
choses mais ça que sauf que le body
language est pas incroyable don qui fait
un peu un peu starlette un peu un peu de
ça mais c'est parce pas négatif
mais je suis assez positif sur tous les
bancs en outre homegrown band chéreau
jabbari griffin du renne ivy moi je vois
vraiment très très peu de red flag
comportementaux
g20 turin
mathurin peut-être jovic peut-être parce
que je les ai vus en europe aussi les
vues bord terrain gelé vue à
l'échauffement et tout donc c'est vrai
qu'on va en fait c'est plus d'infos sur
lui quoi t'es sûr doute on voit pas les
échauffements vois pas ce qui se passe
avant et après les matchs n'ont pas
laissé beaucoup d'américains donc c'est
compliqué mais
bonne question une bonne bonne question
à turin pour attirer mathurin parce que
tu sais que j'ai un truc sur les jours
soft ou mathurin
il n'aime pas le contact quoi et
dans les hôtels moi un joueur qui quand
son basket quand les chiffres aient lieu
il est lavé résultat visuel de montre
autant qu'un jour tu as autant qu'un
jour on n'aime pas aller à la à la
mailloche moi ça ça me pose question ça
me pose problème ok donc
voilà bénédicte mathurin tu vois on jeu
là nous disait hier qu'il fait n'est pas
l'argent qui fait 2 m 01 s que c'est
juste visuels ou est-ce qu parce que le
mec est tout le temps dans le périmètre
avec des flotteurs et où
il fait plus petit jeu même remarque sur
tahiti washington même s'était
d'ailleurs moi vous frustre un peu moins
mais tu as été washington qui tente des
flotteurs un conte 0 quoi alors que je
le pann il est totalement ouvert
et townsend est actuellement très fort
on en reparlera à l'occasion il sonne et
pour le coup lui il est très très très
grande bouche
ouais
apprécie beaucoup
[Musique]
5 je crois je suis plus au dessus un jeu
léger 17e ça mon big band à toujours
voir
les deuxièmes de menthières 3
ouais ça me dérange pas le côté le côté
grande bouche bien que
lui et social c'était vraiment pour moi
le plus que ce que je veux le futur en
nba quoi pour des postes 3,4 limite
small ball five par moment donc je ne
serai pas fait de frottis sanguins ouais
j'ai déjà elle apprécie fortement ses
profits qu'ils sont et tout ce que je
veux en fait il y aura toujours de la
place pour ces gens là donc
quatre choses sur ces profils à ouvrir
mon big world pressé de trouver des gens
dyson daniel fut extrêmement positif sur
lui
sur le comportement at bagis à anna
d'hyères je pense au akkar kessler jenni
williams jean montéro les gens vont se
poser des questions sur jean montéro pas
vraiment à cause du joueur à cause des
choix aussi rentrer en comptant les
choix de carrière
non pas vraiment de pas vraiment de des
choses là dessus
bon je suis donc allée bluff que j'ai
gardé quand même assez haut enfin je les
dis je t'écoute bien calé bloch des
xviiie et calais bluff c'est là ça va
être pile ou face quoi soit soit le jour
éplorée de billets à la fois de ce
contrat où qu'ils soient et ça peut être
un vrai très très bon titulaire j'ai pas
encore temps que je ressens d'abord mes
joueurs qui arrivent pas aller au cercle
qui ont des profondes âge à deux pointes
à tapis smic ça me qui vivent par la
bresse à trois points avait un peu de
mal donc je ne les avais pas je
comprends pas leur excuse moi un char de
la porte à côté parce que c'est juste il
est juste insupportable je comprends pas
pourquoi ce mec n'arrive pas à finir on
peut ni vraiment c'est une énigme
passe carrière ntela 35% à deux ponts a
organisé un concert violence est près du
cirque c'est dégueulasse aussi mais
j'arrive pas à comprendre
j'arrive pas à l'expliquer que calais
bluff soit au sein avait près du cercle
j'étais super compliqué la fin un gros
match comme voleur en a assez des
caprices eur et la moyenne a fait plus
de prem's et voilà c'est la régularité
il en a fait plein d un très bon match
mais bien sûr mais voilà tu vois
l'athlète on voit la vitesse tu vois
l'explosivité tu vois la capacité à
changer de direction et tout et après tu
vois qu'il est au près du panier les
galères à 3 50% et je capte pas je capte
pas pourquoi vous croyez à un pivot ici
je suis totalement comme s'il avait
aucune maîtrise de son corps un peu
comme scotty bang l'an dernier mais ce
calibre à s'expliquer parce qu'il était
très jeune qui n'était pas finie qu'il
avait pas mal évolué en termes de de
corpulence et tout mais calais bluff
c'est mon c'est mon mystère
et peut-être qu'un jour j'aurai une
réponse je te propose on à faire autre
chose les ménages effet bien tourné les
clips on va enchaîner sur un deuxième
joueur et on va sauf si le chat a eu et
je vous passe comme ça le soit en europe
je vous mets là sauf si le tchad veut
qu'on fasse d'abord qui est vrai mais
c'est normal sur thalys halliburton dit
le chat est ce crime et prospects nba où
est-ce qu'on fait le joueur sauf mort et
une bille et
hop hop hop hop vous me dites je vois
guy qui nous pose alors ya une question
de tabriz alors une union militarise
yaghi gay qui nous pose comme question
tout tout tout tout tout qu'est-ce qu'on
peut poser des pensées de l'évolution de
john terry alors je pense qu'on va la
prendre en france la date pour la fin
pour faire qu'une fois qu'on aura fait
tous les jours sinon on n'avancera pas
par ailleurs celui de la fin du premier
tour au second tour de draft on note
deux côtés je me les notes et on fera à
la fin
toc qu'est ce qui manque ivy smith pour
iv dans le tien en garde à la fin on
essaie de rester sur les questions un
peu on a pas que le sujet on nous dit
terry starwizz terrisse diaries
halliburton bombes allaient chanter la
liberté le peuple a voté
alors tiens louise halliburton pour ceux
qui ne qui ne qui ne situe pas c'est le
meneur du parcours d'anna pays servent à
phrase est une formidable qui s'est fait
transféré contre domota sabonis il était
à sacramento c'était le renouveau de
sacramento et puis c'est fait transféré
du côté des pêcheurs du mois de mai il
faudra pas courte avec malcom propre
donne hyper intelligent à l'époque de
sadr a donc ça remonte à il ya deux ans
lui et des sophomores yes pinel avec
très très haut il était 4e de l'ordre
mox pas si tu te rappelles
et alors je sais pas toi tu vas nous
dire moi je l'avais bien plus bas et je
vais faire tout de suite un mea culpa
pour le joueur je ne croyais pas en sa
capacité à se créer un écart déjà à
l'époque
du côté d'iowa state il n'était pas le
porteur de balle principal de l'équipe
terrassière bolton qui maintenant joue à
condezaygues actuellement qui était le
plus gros porteur de balle de l'équipe
et finalement il m'a tuer mme plante et
l'imagerie certaines choses sur les
pourtours de balle et balavoine vais
revoir ma façon de voir les choses mais
toi à l'époque du jour qu'est ce que tu
en penses et tu étais amoureux de lui
est ce que lui aussi tu as promis des
choses faire ou bien des choses en
question est qu'est ce que t'en pense
actuellement
super intéressant parce que à préparer
l'émission j'étais revoir sa page
intérieure et cemac avec plein de
scouting report quand même si je me
sentais pour moi quand je le lis j'ai
tout bon mais j'ai pas assez
mis en valeur pour les choses qu'ils
savaient très bien faire donc ce n'est
pas assez
j'ai passé ans et que ce qu'ils
faisaient était si
rare que sa maison que c'est pour ça
qu'il n'était pas si haut que ça et si
je regarde le
report avec en forger jeu sur pick'n
roll à l'intelligence cuit catch and
shoot
moi c'est ça décembre a travaillé en
deux les polyvalences défensive csssae
point faible tir en sortie de dribble
pas s'étaler sur la ligne haut du corps
c'est ça juste voilà et risi la créative
ses progrès en tirant sortie dribbles
sont anormaux en fait et c'est vraiment
vraiment incroyable de sa part je pense
qu'en fait j'avais vu là j'avais vu ce
qu'était à erize en termes d'évaluation
jugeait pas
venger la valeur que j'avais donnée à
son profil était totalement sous coté en
fait c'est pour ça que je l'avais en 15
3 parce que en fait je rentre une bonne
à trine pas je pense que les joueurs
intelligents les connecteurs sur le
terrain qui font pas d'erreurs à tous
les niveaux qui sont utiles dans tous
les contextes donc iowa state avant
quand il était avec talent un autre
hortons de coeur 1 et freshman horton
tucker
marianne sherlock lindell wigginton et
où il était déjà mon team usa u19 il est
dans le cinq de la compétition et c'est
le connecteur entre kate jane green se
faisait tous ça iowa 2éme année master
du pick and roll master en transition a
toujours été bon toujours utile jamais
on peut de sortir du terrain et passager
puis j'avais pas pour moi à ses données
de crédit à ça je pense que c'est une
vraie bonne leçon on tire toujours des
leçons de ses erreurs qu'ont fait ses
confrères était pour moi une une bonne
chose à avoir sur le cas de tyrese
moi personnellement tu
ce qui m'a appris et on en reparle assez
régulièrement ensemble c'est que quand
tu es un fort porteur de balle sur
pick'n roll même si t'es pas explosif en
saison régulière on s'en fout parce que
la majorité du temps les défenses nba
encore aujourd'hui alors qu'on parle
toujours de switcher sur tous les écrans
et tous vont avoir une défense de pick
and roll ou qui vous va être très bas il
va dropper
et sita vous halliburton un bond qui
vaut ce qu'il avait comme c'est toujours
un phénomène mais afin qu'à 28 l'équipe
animée battu presque une voix off your
boss a nommé m
c'est clair qu'en ce moment plus à votre
défense et n'importe quoi et my amis de
de six mois je vois mes amis a fait de
la trappe sur des morts des roses and de
cul te montre à 2 démarre des roses
année ça me casse les couilles une
chance inouïe
mais où est donc la plupart des
défenseurs d'europe quand même et
c'était un bon petit écran ce que t as
with halliburton a eu avec quand même
rite choses
auparavant
incomplètes à avoir un écart il va
pouvoir sanctionner à mi-distance et est
très efficace sur ce secteur-là est donc
finalement
finalement ça marche bien en playoffs on
verra
mais ce serait déjà où ce n'est plus la
même équipe en playoffs à ce moment là
la question est posée plus tard
complètement
complètement mais c'est surtout que
moi c'était plus le côté tu vois
connecteurs fait pas d'erreur et les en
fait c'est j'ai comparé à scotty barnes
mans l'année dernière déjà je n'arrivais
pas à expliquer pourquoi il y réussit
c'est mais réussissent ils n'avaient pas
le dribble incroyable par la fluidité
incroyable pas le premier pas incroyable
par un tir incroyable mais je ne peux
pas l'éthique des sorties en fait sur le
terrain boudon faut donner un peu de
crédit à sa
réserve et bertone
il est légitime sur un terrain et son
entrée en nba l'an dernier dès le début
à sacramento donc c'est qu'il ya des
raisons là cette année le clip le match
que j'ai flippé joue le cdc le match
atlanta dimanche dernier où outre et en
grand mais 47 48 et halliburton fait un
très bon match aussi c'est sans duarte
ses 100 ans brooke donne ses 100 ans
turner donc c'est halliburton qui drive
tout dans un match où racle à diana
innovation design défend pas il peut pas
défendre et non pas le personnel pour
défendre avec les blessures titi warren
est blessé aussi et c'est un match où il
lâche rien ils sont quasiment proche de
faire le hold up à la fin parce que
tyrese les crises les maintient avec à
zahia jackson avec jaden smith dans
cette étape devance à auch et boris est
que j'adore aussi dégradée pitcher's
donc assez intéressant puis ce match
fermé il fait un chantier incroyable la
pointe notamment et en défense il a un
peu de mal sur air vous il faut le
montrer aussi je pense sont ils des pas
voilà c'est pas un athlète explosif tout
les de toutes les dimensions
ce qui fait
l report le numéro zéro là pour ceux qui
le ceux qui le connaissent pas il ya au
milieu il est ici
ce qui a enfin fort avec lui maintenant
comme cadillac son évolution sur le tir
extérieur et que si tu passes ou l'écran
il sanctionne il punit avec un tir à
trois points si tu essaies de traverser
l'écran comme il joue avec des bons
pivots à lui la de l'espace et du coup
il peut déclencher à deux points ou
comme hiver très mince au tempo une
passe au sol une passe lobée et puis là
cette panoplie là que tu m'entends
parfaitement bien où ils utilisent très
bien la planche routeur
il ya un vrai un toucher terre il ya
toujours eu en outre
donc c'est un joueur sur tous les
secteurs de jeu il récompense très bien
ses faiblesses pardon maîtrisons
excellemment autre chose à laquelle
on est passé à mener pas sa manipulation
visuel à dire rendre son coéquipier lit
parce que je regarde un endroit et je la
passe ailleurs et dort très la mettrait
la mélo ball est ce qu
il est il et il est top se sont
impliqués dans l'est avec un énorme
driving qui qu'avant il a une force de
bras pour
pratiquer l autre côté la porte de
peut-il des étapes aussi pour lui parce
qu'ils se connaissent et parce que c'est
un vrai partenaire de drive in teak et
piqué dans la tu vois là il c'est un
petit pull up simple je pensais pas
qu'ils sitôt et le maîtriserait parce
qu'à cause de la de l'âme la mécanique
la catapulte dont je parlais dans
l'article qu'on avait un peu tous deux
doutent qu'ils avaient les super
pourcentage à trois points mais parce
que c'était brutt catch and shoot oui en
fait ça à mécanique il a un petit peu
nettoyer il a encore un peu la même île
et hop / / /
du coulobre donc un super super relation
là une magnifique passe et un dunk doit
in washington dans ses jambes
whiteknighttwo le rookie n'est
d'épaisseur dans le ventre
qui va très vite
sa part de très bas mais ça va très vite
et encore tu montres et sur le jean qui
tiendront le moral entre une belle passe
à la loupe ces bonus un parce que parce
que moïse l'écart est fait mais en
compte la finition c'est pas beau du
sein
c'est dieu qui nous donne sa mémoire
encore une fois tu vois c'est qu'il est
très rapidement le jeu et il fait tout
de suite le bon choix est ce que j'ai un
tir ouvert mi distance je prends est-ce
que j'ai une passe je la prends donc là
par un pont une fois le flotteur phall
fatale eu le bras roulé même bulletin
c'est vraiment à l'ancienne pendant ces
capteurs à jay simpson je sais pas si tu
vois michigan compagnie king avec à
oklahoma city moi dans l'équipe de blue
c'est en fait
moi c'était vraiment le profil de
connecteurs je trouve que c'est tu vois
souvent on aime réfléchir parlée par les
postes où les rôles et le rôle de
connecteurs le rôle qu alonso chez toi
et les joueurs ils font sens on parce
qu'en fait ils font tout le temps le bon
choix ils sont capables de faire tout le
temps les choses les bons choix balle en
main la balle en main que je joue à côté
des stars si tu les mets tout seul par
contre en créateur unique ton équipe ne
sera pas incroyable non parce mention et
de
[Musique]
ce profil là est extrêmement rare les
profils de drenthe green aussi pour moi
c'est le connecteur ultime de raisons
green
et on voit quand il n'est pas là ce qui
se passe du côté des warriors mais une
très bonne position défensive la kiffer
sur une très bonne rotation et la région
d andré hunter tient un peu le choc des
aliments active et le force à un poulpe
contestées c'est une des bonnes actions
défensives que j'ai vu de lui mais
je crois qu'après sur le pick and roll
se précipite un peu et on voit la
création de séparation et pas incroyable
que ça va donner de l'eau gallinari
normalement il doit faire mieux tu vois
contre danilo gallinari tu dois fermer
mais c'est là aussi la limite les
limites athlétiques de tyrese wei po
paris n'est pas explosif
gallinari lui laisse un peu d'espacé et
ne peut pas vraiment changé de change de
vitesse il veut accélérer décédé mais
c'est pas hyper super toujours aussi
petit périmètre que ça est-ce que tu as
with halliburton parce que les gens
n'ont pas les sur les réseaux aussi
éculé je rejoins ce que tu disais par
rapport à une équipe faible est-ce que
depuis son début de carrière en nba la
pop contexte idéal dans les deux équipes
c'est à dire à sacramento je joue avec
des arômes fox donc je suis le deuxième
porteur de vol qui va rendre ma star
meilleur et a coûté ndjana alors même
s'il est souvent blessé je me redonne
qui est aussi un monsieur propre absolue
et qui veulent un fusil fier et qui va
lui ouvrir beaucoup d espace peut donc
il avait aussi des bons les bons mais
bon la bonne narrative à sacramento si
on perdait ce n'était pas sa faute et on
était super heureux de ce qu'ils
faisaient à juste titre parce que
c'était un jeune joueur qui s'apprêtait
directement on n'est pas la pression de
gagner à indiana il fait des stats il
doit en vingt dix depuis qu'il est au
players le but c'est pas gagné des
matches qui nous quitte si les pères des
camps défense il est pas bon on pas se
mentir c'est pas un problème donc il ya
aussi la bonne narrative ans ne tarit
pas libre antonia et tous les gens sont
extrêmement positifs élogieux à juste
titre c'est parce que si on lui demande
pas de gagner des matches et quantité à
sacramento c'était plus la bonne
surprise le très bon on quitte au fox
qui prenait un peu sur les doigts comme
ça ça allait moins bien donc je pense tu
vois que pour le moment c'est tout va
bien pour lui et
ayant pas il ya une bonne environnement
pour jouer collectivement comme je la
très bien dit mais aussi pas vraiment la
pression du résultat très rapide parce
qu'il a écarté en 12 aussi d'accord que
la limite pour lui c'est quand il se
sera
titularisé d'un connecteur mais ça
pourra jamais être la star de l'egypte
avec lui mais qui rend toute l'équipe
meilleure mais il sera voilà c'est pas
le star sait pas mais d'y retourner en
25 15 et c'est un
métronome c'est un launch the wall live
15 out qui est plus polyvalent que l'on
double offensivement
et voilà les jours ce jour ce genre de
profil
ouais pour moi ça peut être j'ai changé
mais ça par rapport à l'année dernière
où un manhwa je pensais que ça pouvait
être sur ton quatrième ou cinquième
titulaire d'une équipe qui a de grosses
ambitions je pense que ça peut être le
troisième maintenant j'aurai mais
comment fait il ouais voilà mais je
pense qu'il a vraiment il m'a vraiment
prouver des choses dans le chott making
les améliorations c'est un gros
travailleur en termes de qi basket en
termes de d'éthique de travail
cct top et ça aussi il faut défendre
souccot un peu là qui est une surcote
moi je trouve que le souccot pendre et
donc en fait les règles et tyrese bas
en fait je parierais pas sur le fait
qu'il va devenir très bon même dans des
temps des endroits où dans des aspects
de son jeu où il est pas il était
incroyable donc je pense que ça peut
vraiment être un excellent titulaire nba
je pense qu'il peut avoir fait une ou
deux sélections all star et après les
sélections de stars pour moi ça veut pas
dire grand chose pour l'état aux joueurs
je parle puisse envoyer une bille et je
ne vois pas être all nba cela va être un
des six meilleurs garde de la ligne sur
une saison plus parler comme ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est un je prends
énormément de plaisir à regarder indiana
depuis qu'il est là j'ai dû regarder
aller la moitié de leur match parce que
je veux voir à zahia jackson pour moi d
énorme flash à la robert williams
franchement
on sent dans sa protection certes
j'adore auch et brice est gelée va
remplacer gordon session avec duarte et
puis j'adore tyrese donc très très très
très hâte de voir ce qu'ils vont faire à
la draft prochain c'est une équipe jeune
qui est devenu
pianiste passé avec quelques beaucoup de
gens attendent de voir était contre
attentats gm mais regardez atlanta donc
c'était la bonne occasion je ne sais pas
c'est pas mon kiff
mais parce que parce qu'à chaque fois il
nous dit nous nous défoncer tout
simplement et que trion que c'est toi tu
les aimes d'amour moi je supporte pas
j'en reviens à chaque fois que quelqu'un
lui met un écran mobile dans la tête
mais après voilà c'est un excellent
joueur il fonctionne que s'il est
capable de déborder des sentiments aussi
forts c'est que vous et les couleurs
c'est que ça marche c'est que ça alors
c'est un jour qui te rend à différentes
rayon de doute là dessus c'est assez
réussi et ça n'est que tel joueur six
nouvelles à la draft une petite question
taboue halliburton slash ivy ça vous
parle comme association voilà je donne
serait sur le départ cet été jallet deux
sujets majeurs sous les yeux du coup vu
mon deuxième écran un package pour notre
flotte
alors on peut commencer par aller bolton
a heavy alors forcément elle vit aussi
le lien avec lydiane à
nous
toi tu penserais quoi de ce binôme et si
jamais tu es pas fan quel genre de
profil alors on va on va se dire que tu
y est c'est évident parce que tout le
monde le veut que jane et smith est
évident parce que tout le monde le veut
mais tu juin mais qui tient comme ça
aura complètement en 4 6
qu'est ce que tu as aussi est ce que tu
vas sur ivy est ce que tu vas sur autre
chose
jean rampon d'un point de vue purement
fille tant qu purement un feat parce que
ce que moi ne pas vu du potentiel n'aime
pas mais où est ce qu'on fera mais si tu
vois les jeux lego c'est bien sûr parce
que ça peut marcher parce que avoir une
vraie complémentarité
c'est pas du tout les mêmes profils en
fait tyrese ils peuvent te montres que
tu es résident excellent catch and shoot
en fait donc si tu veux aussi si dieu
veut donner un peu de traces des ballons
de pour faire du drive-in qui cache des
navy ou faut mettre beaucoup de pression
versa ce qui manque énormément atteint
rizki normes ce qui manque énormément
indiana ce qu'avait tel risque j'étais
avec deron fois que c'est à dire la
pression sur le cercle la possibilité de
vraiment pouvoir
drive efforts vers le panier ce qui fait
que quand tu travailles fort vers le
panier bas ça a créé plein de jeunes à
créer des décalages je pense que ça peut
vraiment bien fonctionné on peut bien
fonctionner peut y avoir une belle
complémentarité défensivement fais pas
trop de soucis et non je pense que ça
peut vraiment fonctionné la question et
en tuant 3 et comme graines et smith
sont partis moi je pense que je peux
quand même 20 de chéreau en demande
générique pour le potentiel et parce que
sur 2 me taire je pense que
l'association peut être très
intéressante aussi mais en tout cas
l'association equi levy serait super que
super intéressante aussi bas ce serait
hyper excitant c'est un peu le feu la
glace
j'ai un peu d'épaisseur et m'a demandé
la même chose sur what's app et je lui
ai dit oui ça peut totalement le faire
au début halliburton qui a beaucoup le
ballon qui met en place le jeu qui peut
accélérer d'un seul coup il faudra voir
si donner un avis il va confirmer deux
saisons aux tirs ou si ça s'est un peu
tronqué aussi parce que au temple de
mécanique pas hyper hyper académique
adjoint de la libye se pose d'un aussi
et et 25% premières années 40 pour son
2ème année peut-être juste milieu mais
les très bonnes stats d'un avis sur la
la le high school c'est un truc que
beaucoup de gens mettaient en avant il
souffre est très bien
ouais sur les quatre années la volée
très bon pour quentin petit jeu c'est
très bien moi aussi j'aime j'aime pas la
mécanique en sorties toutes
les voir déjà les barreaux fiba ce
qu'ils faisaient parce qu'il affective
ec mais tout le monde disait qu'en fait
avant cette année là il avait toujours
bien shooté sauf sa première année a
perdu en fuite donc
ta avoir fait avoir je n'ai
en tout cas de me montrer qu'ils font
chez moi j'ai lancé un petit des zones
touchées avec indiana et chez les choses
de donner la vie et je me fais qu'il
fait avec cette paire là
est-ce que alors est-ce que malcom braff
donne serait sur le départ il ya moyen
et malcommode donne va intéresser
beaucoup d' équipe et je pense notamment
nos amis delà de la big apple
du côté de new york et là tu pètes
récupérer des choses un peu intéressante
qu'est-ce que tu amènerait
si tu vas pas la draft pour cette équipe
qu'est ce que tu amènerait comme type de
profit pour renforcer tout ça et pour
permettre à halliburton de passer un cap
si j'avais pas tranquille nuland je
comprends cette optique le ndi de
d'intérieur ip raté qui écrit murder
et j'apporte un deuxième gros porteur de
balle pourtant que je pense que le banc
des chiens ou peut être un super fit ont
fait un deuxième gros porteur de balle
un mec qui est capable de de ce christ
on tire quand il veut d'exceller sur le
mid rennes et donner un peu de talent
ternes at-il vosges d'épaisseur ce qui
est parfois un peu stéréotypé en ce
moment parce qu'un joueur comme comme ça
en deuxième un vrai les meilleurs et
aussi un genre qui peut se créant que
ces choses là sont de son pour chercher
ses rares comme profil mais c'est ce
qu'ils espèrent avoir je pense en
détention dans l'approché nord est
franchement lire un scénario ou
prototypes par contre tu a imaginé par
odyx qui par contre un pic draft ils ont
deux
deux choix assez bien placé et ne
peuvent ils peuvent avoir une
reconstruction hyper rapide l'épaisseur
êtres très excitant très rapidement
guigui qui nous disent qu'on est sûr que
halliburton restait d'annapolis sur le
long terme qu'a lancé la nba glisse donc
longtemps on sait maintenant deux ans en
attendant je pense que les fans vont
vous l'adorez que côté concerne plus de
reconstruction il attaque parfaitement
tous les projets de reconstruction
halliburton donc
donc on peut compter dessus quand même
quelques années
je t'avais puis de toute façon il va
signer son ils vont lui donner
d'extension donc
réalité
il valide et dois l'accepter je peux
compter un contrat au barça dépend en
fait ça dépend ce qu'ils vont en avant
puis c'est en terme de est ce qu'il va
faire une roulette billets ou est ce
qu'il va faire une chose comme ça donc
je pense qu'il lui doit donc quand même
une belle extension le système est fait
pour qu'en fait
c'est avait fait pour que tu puisses
gala de menton jours sur 7 de premiers
contrats et donc ça devrait faire comme
ça
oui on peut on pourrait partir sur 1,25
million l'année ce serait pas noël juste
très surprenant
complètement
bah écoute on va pouvoir passer ou
prospects nba avec qui gagnent mais on
va faire un petit point au niveau des
bras kate pour voir si on a des
actualisations
et pendant que ça on va prendre les
questions qu'on a mis de côté tout à
l'heure il n'est une laque yves ndjock
avec jean-paul eaubonne quiero
ces derniers pas d'avoir qui demandaient
ce qu'ils trouvent que le premier pas et
le haendel de deux bonnes quiero sont un
peu moyen pour être un premier porteur
de balle et s'interrompt à une bille est
ce que toi tu y prends moi j'y crois
très très forte en juriste randle de
l'année dernière près
d'un joueur qui fait un joueur qui fait
quasiment 2007 115 kg
c'est pas normal qu'ils bougent aussi
bien pour sa part sa taille là on l'a de
8 208 qui sur ses kilos sur le site il a
pris depuis le premier le premier pas
franchement en fait c'est pas qu'il a un
premier pas et on donne un peu compliqué
c'est qu'il fait trop de spin ou froid
il est vraiment un poison
spin move voilà il ya le contexte duke
est pas le meilleur où il respecte singh
pas bon d qui drive ya mark williams qui
est là il ya un autre il ya deux
défenseurs sur lui
mais en fait je pense que pense que
paolo
i
pour sa taille le combinaison rapport
taille poids
qualité ballot ma vision est superbe
super avec moi j'y crois j'y cros et
apollo gip rapports en option numéro une
une équipe qui gagne le titre mais parce
que dans cette option n'a pas pour moi
et parce qu en fait y en a pas dans tous
tes draft c'est normal mais
mais
propre rôle aux études par exemple
est ce que
j'avais tatum au tuc fois ce dernier qui
est l'option numéro 1 d'une équipe qui
vise le titre je pense que les celtics
alors si c'est parce que les skis sont
encore un peu jeunes ils ont des
objectifs là dessus une équipe qui a
fait un café trop deux finales deux
contre deux pics tatum et la croix c'est
simplement alors à l'époque il était aux
jeunes mais maintenant c'est vraiment un
freak roulis dans la bulle doit être
dans la lune c'est dans la bulle c'était
le meilleur joueur de l'équipe pas la
lorraine où il est rookie c'est un truc
un peu bizarre qui se passe mais mes
compétences à cette puce son équipement
et donc par rapport à ce jour deux
jours-là cette potentialité là ce que
toi tu crois où tu penses que kiel à la
faune en eau ou bien une mentalité où un
style de jeu qui permet pas d'aller
aussi loin que ce que fait peut-être
tourner du côté deux bosses
alors pour moi j'ai jeûné je n'ai pas
dans le même tire que tu as tout
simplement sur le tir qu'est-ce qu'on
sous-coté vraiment le potentiel de choc
making de de tatum qui était assez
irréelle qui n'était pas mis en avant à
duke parce qu'on préférait donner la
balle à luc hennart des greffes en
haleine chacun fait ses choix
n'était pas vraiment les meilleurs les
meilleurs choix mais
alors j'ai tatum un tir au dessus mais
par contre je vois paulo
je le préfère
le préfère dans les prospects de duke
entre guillemets duke ces dernières
années près ferme paulo à barrett je
préfère paulo a
à a comment il s'appelait à ingram
pourtant j'ai même bien bordeaux ni
grave mais je contacte plus clair paulo
parce que paulo il va faire des choses
simples billets parce qu'il va pouvoir
mettre la pression sur le cercle et ça
c'est super important
moi je suis comme cueillir un peu d'eux
depuis un an voilà il ya un peu de chute
un peu paulo les gens sont un peu je
sais pas problème de défense dribble
tout ça il n'y a pas un contexte
incroyable et je trouve que moi il m'a
impressionné quand même à tous les
matchs à une dizaine d'actions je fais
moi
mais vraiment très impressionnant mais
je pense que ça doit du fait aussi
costaud l'état l'hymne de la parodie
espionne
onguents match mixte effet les notes de
chaque joueur ouais t'as jabbari ce
missile à a+ ab plus as tu manges rôtir
versatilité polyvalence ivy là que des
as des as plus le crâne c'est pareil et
bong héros et lui met fin il lui prenne
trois critères ils mettent eux tirent à
physicalité à plus bas prix m défense et
moi et comme max schmitz a dit parce que
wes piana dit bonne quiero défense et
moins et qui a pas d'autres points forts
notre modibo moins bonnes qui roulait un
peu nul en fait et chutes dont on
connaît le
storytelling sang et des lignes
narratives complètement con pas à jouer
énormément moyens modèles ya un gars qui
peut arriver dans n'importe quelle
équipe une bille et claqué au sol tu
prends n'importe quelle équipe nba la
deux du fond de la cuve au sol tu mets
bunker où il peut mettre un point et tu
peux créer une attaque alors après tu
gagnes pas forcément énormément de
matches et urine pas forcément d'autres
sites mais il ya des matches avec taille
dans l'année une donc vous calmer les
gens en pagaille un bâtiment c'est ça et
tu peux créer une attaque autour de
pôles eaubonne quiero et complétée
derrière il ya peu de joueurs qui
peuvent faire autant et aussi vite et
comme tu dis peut marquer de partout
donc
il alla il a le corps et la mentalité
d'alpha
il aime ça il est un entourage très
positif et des parents qui mettent le
collectif en tout cas le coaching le
front-office le style mon amour bon
il a le basket donc moi je suis très
très très chaud et c'est en termes de
potentialités pour moi et les moins
élevés quand certains domaines par
exemple je normal logique et ça c'est un
truc que je disais au chat live très
perso où je privilégie tout le temps un
porteur de balle surtout on est liée aux
premiers choix et c'est pour ça que je
les que je les en deux notre question
sur renvoi jeu avant que tu es tu on
parle de kimia 2 murray ait su rester
simple pourquoi aucun gros continuent à
terre neuvien et billets dernier mme
song c'est brad van den braak dit parce
qu'en fait c'est mieux d'être coach aux
initiés parce que tu fais ce que tu veux
toi qui recrutent les joueurs toi qui
fais jouer comme tu veux tu as par gm
n'a pas un président des opérations
basket qu'elle a qui te dit que tu un
peu tu peux trade était joueur la porte
à des transferts pour te te faire
plaisir et plus simple en fait de ce
qu'était vraiment une mainmise beaucoup
plus sur le type de choses et avec des
styles avec des salaires qui sont aussi
qui suivent aussi donc parce que c'est
pour ça moi je pense que c'est pour ça
que j'ai raison de 8 5 millions $ primes
et cela il a la mainmise sur les choix
et les choix de jeu les choix du roster
froid ton cul parce que c'est ça je
pense que céder l'une des raisons
principales et puis donc je vais
chercher la page de keegan murray vas-y
une vague
une vague de coach lancé par boîte
stevens qui a à tout va tout déchirer ta
fred aubert qui arrive du côté de berne
c'est dramatique tablier donovan le
constat est très mitigé du côté de
cassis par rapport à ce qu'on pouvait
avoir écouté le florida tu as eu l'échec
instantanée
de notre ami john beeline voilà merci de
2001 qui a dit que ses joueurs étaient
des deux médailles a dit que c'était des
milliards mais il se serait trompé
donc je pense que c'est pas recyclés que
ce cycle là c'est un peu calmée et qu'on
va avoir un peu de temps avant de
retrouver un coach
n 6 et qui parce que le step est ce que
vont donner les assistants c'est à des
assistants du mois qui viennent en nba
et qui après repartent du fait que le
nouveau coach de louisville c'est un
ancien gros assistant calipari l'a fait
deux ans au stade d'un staff des knicks
là il y en avoir le poste à louisville
dentsu de majorque était le côte
pacifique il ya eu deux cas la
progression stable donc il ya des
mouvements et pour prendre une